We challenged
30 table tennis players
and if they can win
one point
against all three of us
They win $100
First round
Emil
Okay hi!
Come on Emil!
NO!
Good lob
That was a good lob!
Oh
Penholder!
This is interesting
Very good backhand!
Thanks man!
So there’s
three so far
That have passed
Okay hi!
HI!
Welcome to the table!
Okay!
That one
That’s what I wanted!
It didn’t go well...
GRRRR!
Let’s go!
YEAH!
Yeah!
On to the next round!
That was crazy!
I’m scared of this guy!
Okay Emil good luck!
Nice!
Good rally!
The pressure is high!
Green side long pips
Good one!
Sorry!
That’s brutal!
The pressure is high!
Too high
What am I gonna do?
Backhand serve
Backhand serve?
Yes
It touched!
Touched?
Donovan
Did it touch?
No touch!
That’s the second time
it happens to me!
That was level 1!
Westside!!
This is gonna be
a very interesting
battle
There’s one slot
The first person
Who can prove
that they’ve subscribed
to Pongfinity
Moves on to the next round!
I have i have!
She found it!
Sometimes it pays off
to be subscribed
to Pongfinity
so if you haven’t done that yet
Remember to do it now!
So 15 players
From Westside
got through level 1
Next they will face Miikka
to make it to the final boss
Okay Miikka
How you feeling?
I’m feeling confident!
You know what I smell?
DEFEAT!
Come on Alfred!
The mob
is a bit intimidating there
Cleared the first one!
Very nice!
Come on guys!
It makes a huge difference
If I win the serve
I’m pretty confident
but if I lose the serve
anything can come from that side
Okay I lost the serve
The pressure is so high!
Yeah
It’s one chance
Exactly!
It’s brutal!
He got the serve!
Watch out for the serve!
This is a good one!
Really fast
And watch out
for the forehand after that!
Thank you!
Okay any strategy?
Hit the ball really hard
That’s good!
Very good
Well played!
Good receive
Ripping backhand
Miikka, take it easy!
You had a chance there!
Only Kyle!
I got away easy on that one
Next up we have our loyal
Pongfinity subscriber!
Lucky subscriber!
Is back on the table
I’m gonna give her the serve
I’m so scared!
Thank you
Only one survivor?
Kyle!
So we have two mini challenges
and we’ll bring back
four players
all together
The first game was a bounce contest
The last two players bouncing
would proceed to the final
We tried making it difficult
but players were passing
even the hardest challenges
The final spots were decided
with a sitting down race
were we saw some
superhuman agility
to secure the first two spots
in the final five!
Next game was simply
to get the ball
into the box
with some interesting techniques
and a solid target shot
we had two winners
completing the final five
Okay so we have five people
for the final level
The final boss
The Sensei
Now
something
never seen before
Otto’s going for a run!
What is this?
That’s all
He’s warm
So, made it to the final!
Yes sir!
Can’t beleive I made it!
Let’s do this
Oh yeah
Let’s do it!
Whoever manages to
win the point
They will win $100
The final round!
Come on!
That was crazy!
Thank you!
Sensei gave no mercy at all there!
Good luck Sensei
you’re gonna need it!
You almost made it though!
Thank you
You wanna serve?
Yes
You always have to ask!
you never know
Nasty serve
Kyle is the only one
who managed to beat Miikka
So that’s on the line
No pressure!
Brutal!
*Miss*
We have our winner!
Let’s go!!
Well done
We have our first winner!
Congrats man!
That’s yours
Thank you very much!
The champion
of Westside table tennis LA
Alfred
Congratulations!